vamos a resolver algunos problemas
interesantes de perímetro y área vamos a
empezar con este que se ve padrísimo que
tiene una estrella y dice lo siguiente
el perímetro de cada uno de los
triángulos externos es 30 por ejemplo
aquí el perímetro del eje es igual a 30
estos lados que estoy marcando con verde
en longitud suman 30 vale y lo mismo con
este este este y este luego dice luego
dice el perímetro de f g h i j es 50 es
50 o sea si nos fijamos en este
pentágono tenemos que es de perímetro 50
al sumar todos estos lados azules nos
queda 50 kva y lo que nos preguntan es
cuál es el perímetro de la estrella de
la estrella osea queremos encontrar la
suma de todos estos lados
lfa
este de acá estoy acá todos estos que
estoy pintando en naranja vale bueno
creo que se ve la idea déjame acabar de
pintarlos este de acá
este de acá y también estaría acá está
muy bien bueno para determinar el
perímetro de la estrella lo que tenemos
que hacer es sumar los perímetros de
todos estos triángulos y luego quitar
las bases porque las bases no son parte
del perímetro no están alrededor de la
figura entonces vamos a hacer eso le voy
a poner aquí que el perímetro el
perímetro
de la estrella de la estrella es igual
al perímetro que colaboran los
triángulos externos que voy a poner en
verde le voy a poner al perímetro
perímetro de cinco triángulos en este
triángulo quedó muy feo triángulos
externos
externos ok pero a eso tenemos que
restar tenemos que restar las bases de
los triángulos porque éstas no están en
el perímetro entonces hay que restar las
bases bases de cinco triángulos
exteriores exteriores muy bien ahora sí
vamos a utilizar la información que nos
dan tenemos que el perímetro de cada uno
de los triángulos es 30 y hay 5 de ellos
de esta forma aquí tenemos que la parte
verde es igual a 5 por 30 o sea 150 y a
eso tenemos que restar tenemos que
restar las bases de los cinco triángulos
pero las bases justo forman el pentágono
f g h i j entonces tenemos que restar
los 50 que nos dice que tiene de
perímetro vale entonces esto de aquí es
igual a 150 menos 50 que es 100 y por lo
tanto el perímetro de la estrella es
decir muy bien vamos a otro problema
ahora vamos a este cuadrilátero de acá
aquí esta figura tiene cuatro lados es
un cuadrilátero pero no la hemos
estudiado mucho de este lado tiene lados
rectos y aquí algo que parece como un
triángulo esto de aquí se llama un
trapecio
y bueno la idea para encontrar el área
de este trapecio que es lo que nos piden
es dividir el trapecio en dos figuras
que conozcamos bien es la misma
estrategia que tuvimos en el vídeo
pasado para encontrar el área de los
triángulos verdad entonces vamos a hacer
exactamente lo mismo que antes lo que
vamos a hacer es bajar una perpendicular
desde a hasta de s hasta el segmento de
ce y vamos a llamar a este punto al cual
llega la perpendicular e y me vas a
decir bueno para qué sirve eso tiene
muchas ventajas observa este ángulo
recto cuando esté aquí está en ángulo
recto esté acá también es ángulo recto
porque justo bajamos la perpendicular
este aquí es ángulo recto entonces estoy
acá también porque esta es paralela está
vale entonces aquí tenemos una figura
con cuatro ángulos rectos o sea un
rectángulo y de este lado tenemos un
triángulo con un ángulo recto un
triángulo rectángulo eso está muy padre
por qué
esta área ya la podemos separar en el
área de estas dos figuras bueno ahora
vamos a aprovechar que en un rectángulo
los lados opuestos son iguales este 7 lo
podemos pasar para acá este lado también
mide 7 este 6 lo podemos pasar para aquí
abajo déjame ponerlo con otro color
o sea está este segmento s es igual a 6
quizás debería apuntar eso sea como ave
como ave es igual a 6 eso implica que
eso implica que s es igual a 6 c es
igual a 6 y más aún eso también nos
ayuda a encontrar de por qué es lo que
falta para llegar a 9 teniendo 6
entonces eso que falta es justamente 3
verdad entonces de d es igual a 3 este
cachito de acá es igual a 3 déjame dejar
bien claro que el 9 era la longitud
original para que no nos confundamos muy
bien entonces qué sucede pues nuestro
trapecio queda dividido en este
rectángulo
perdón en este triángulo rectángulo y en
este rectángulo de acá entonces el área
la podemos calcular como el área del
rectángulo que es 6 por 7 6 por 7 base
por altura más el área del triángulo
rectángulo que es un medio un medio de
la base que es 3 por la altura que es 7
muy bien 6 por 7 es 42
le voy a poner aquí que es 42 ya eso
tenemos que restar un medio de 21 un
medio de 21 es 10.5 pues nos queda 42
10.5 y por lo tanto concluimos que el
área del trapecio abc de es igual a 52
52.5 muy bien entonces ya tenemos dos
problemas resueltos vamos al último que
se ve un poco más espantoso y dice lo
siguiente tenemos estas figuras y súper
rara no sabemos qué es y nos dicen que
todos los ángulos son rectos y nos dan
algunas pocas medidas y lo que nos piden
es determinar el perímetro como le vamos
a hacer para determinar esto si tenemos
bien poquito
bueno pues aquí vamos a utilizar otro
truco que no hemos practicado mucho que
consiste en trasladar segmentos aquí me
refiero con trasladar segmentos mira por
ejemplo este segmento de aquí este
segmento que está aquí ha costado lo voy
a trasladar para aquí arriba lo voy a
trasladar para entonces simplemente lo
copié que sucede pues queda justo
empezando aquí verdad porque este es
este de aquí es recto ahora lo que voy a
hacer es trasladar otro segmento más voy
a trasladar ahora este igual éste lo
traslado para acá arriba el plan es que
al final tengamos una figura que sí
conozcamos y bueno esta figura va a ser
un rectángulo ahora déjame trasladar
este segmento de aquí lo voy a trasladar
para acá y finalmente voy a trasladar
este segmento de acá en color morado
para aquí arriba entonces ve está
padrísimo esto la longitud de estos
cuatro lados es simplemente ahora la
longitud de este cacho de acá pero con
este caso de acá entre todos suman 7
déjame seguir haciendo esto para que
veas por qué sucede entonces ahora lo
que voy a hacer es trasladar este
segmento este pequeño segmento azul para
acá y este pequeño segmento azul para
acá este que mide 2 no lo voy a
trasladar porque ya sé que mide 2 y este
de acá tampoco entonces el siguiente que
voy a trasladar es este que queda a la
derecha estoy acá en color rosa mexicano
lo voy a pasar para acá a esta en color
rosa mexicano y entonces observemos lo
que sucede nuestros segmentos
desconocidos que estaban allá dentro en
la figura se convirtieron en lados de un
rectángulo entonces ahora como ya
hacemos para determinar el perímetro
bueno olvidándonos tantito de estos dos
de aquí que ahorita tenemos que
contemplar verdad tenemos que el
perímetro el perímetro
el perímetro es igual al perímetro de
este rectángulo entonces estoy acá mide
6 estoy acá mide 7 todos estos ángulos
son rectos porque aquí abajo nos dice
que son rectos y así lo seguimos
copiando entonces el perímetro es igual
a 6 más 7 aníbal revés verdad puse los
lados al revés déjame borrarle este era
7 y éste era 6 entonces bueno da lo
mismo para la suma pero para el dibujo
no entonces es 67 66 + 7 vale entonces
esto de aquí es el perímetro del
rectángulo pero hay que recordar que nos
faltan estos dos lados que miden 2
entonces hay que sumar ahora más 2 y
finalmente más 2 y así el perímetro de
toda esta figura que teníamos que ahora
tiene lados de colores es 6 + 7 x 13 + 6
son
19 7 son 26 26 más 2 son 28 más 2 son 30
y así el perímetro de esta figura es
igual a 30 y con eso terminamos nuestros
tres problemas interesantes de perímetro
y área